all right so in case I tell her you're
here right here where's my ear they're
so sound perfect yeah all right good
because this one needs to pop out in
case we like talking oh yeah because if
that's closure high reject nation you're
nailing this sally Lomonaco is here it's
been like three weeks three years it's
been a few years since you've been here
how you doing buddy I'm doing good wow
that's a very very like how am i doing
take this in answer it well you look
good you look healthy
you look happy are you yeah it's good
guys I want to sit here in awkward
silence I hate you that's all right we
need to get that out of the way so we
can get onto a path of forgiveness guys
we're gonna watch me Arab City I saw the
teaser trailer which looks awesome Salim
no no one cause you saw better yes call
me zone we can't call you that okay I'm
really excited for this movie I think
you look the teaser was awesome as a
matter of fact I drove a hour to see my
cousin yesterday and the entire time I
was listening to Queen so yeah I'm very
excited Queens a great song I like fat
bottom girls I used to pray to God and
be like apologizing the fact that you
belong in a different era all right well
let's watch this video one two three
remix it ease it has a Live Aid
performance yeah it is we worry Malik
yeah the show I also write songs lead
singer just quit I'm gonna need someone
you damn right you on the radio we need
to get experiment 1 hysterical Queen
[Music]
fortune favors the bold more do you need
to know I make music I want to give the
audience a song that they can perform
[Music]
that's good
[Applause]
beautiful I just need a bit of time
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
you're alleging we're all engines Wow is
that real extra holy oh man I can
already tell him to cry oh my gosh she
comes up the day after my birthday oh
I'll try to remember to wish you a happy
birthday
I'll try he'll text need a later I
really see them Raimi Malick rammie
rammie rammie Malick yeah it looks like
he's really embodying it cuz when I was
listening to Queen we plugged in my
iphone and was so we could watch the
music videos over on the road looking at
the way his body language is doing all
those things and like he's moving
exactly like Freddie Mercury he's an
incredible actor I'm super stoked for
this I thought it was gonna be kind of
like a documentary type style movie but
this looks so good like I can already
tell them to cry oh yeah it's a very
colorful palette this movie like the
everything has this kind of golden
glossy look to it which is pretty cool
to me because a lot of times do you
imagine biopic that can be kind of a
gritty looking film I kind of like that
it has a sort of bright look to it
because this guy has a pretty dark life
towards the last few years of his career
there's the end of his life I just
learned yesterday that when he revealed
to the public that he had AIDS
he died the very next day so he worked
very hard a I'm just in general having a
very private life and they kind of hint
at that here what more do you need to
know I make music then towards the end
he had to work extra hard to keep his
private life even that much more private
what I find funny about these trailers
is there's so much fun and excitement to
the to the music and that's what should
be focused on but they're not hinting it
all about how dark it's probably gonna
get super dark towards the end like Mo's
biopics
audiences aren't ready for that yet
goose
not preparing you for that to come at
all I've seen what what rainy Malek can
do it's going to get intense it's gonna
get heavy you can feel it but I'm so
ready for it and arguably their most
monumental performance that I think
that's what they're hitting ours and the
wife beater hauled him wide at the Live
Aid which is a 1990 the year I was born
that's right I know a couple of music
history facts that's all I really know I
kind of even forgot what it was for I
think it's like AIDS awareness or
something but I think he was like shy to
get on it you know I'm gonna stop
talking before so I sound like that I
actually know I'm talking about one
really I don't
all I know is it's very performance I
really did Pirates of the Caribbean at
Worlds and Beckett yeah he's the I guess
the music producer now because I grew up
listening to Queen I never registered
just how experimental they actually are
with their music I think it's gonna be
fun to see that I'm just wondering how
much of this are they really gonna span
of Freddie Mercury's life
come on at Bohemian Rhapsody their
biggest song of all time their most one
of the most experimental songs is a good
idea it looks like we're covering a lot
of how these songs were made yeah and
then a lot of the monumental concerts
then we also got to get the personal
life explore his bisexuality the
marriage he had at one point for like
this concert film yeah what about all
that personal life stuff that we all
want to see - yeah I hope this movie
does a good job because even though he
had a rather dark personal life I hope
that it does a good job at remember at
just leaving you with the feeling of
honoring the legacy he left behind with
Queen and it's probably gonna be super
inspiring to like artists that think
they're not you know normal yeah that's
true
like youtubers complicated classic rock
growing up all my life like Queen just
always had this different sound to it it
can't be Queen they were kind of like a
rock opera cuz they always had this
operatic art it's variable
factor they made it mainstream is like
insane there's beautiful stuff and then
I think this looks like a really really
damn good film I'm glad that it's an
IMAX is the exact kind of film I wanna
watch a nightmare thanks so much for
being here salamander the Sallee of the
Lomonaco you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation and hey click that
notification Belka subscribe button suck
check out Sallie on her YouTube channel
it's a channel with YouTube content the
pin comment district go there and check
us on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is music video
coverage a whole bunch of goodies would
love to have you become a patronage act
today
[Music]